in Germany the country's Environment
Minister has called for radical action
to tackle climate change speaking at
international climate talks here in
Berlin she backed calls were attacks on
carbon emissions the proposal puts her
at odds with Chancellor on lemarchal who
dresses that conference later today the
carbon tax is one of the possibilities
under discussion for countries to meet
commitments made in the landmark Paris
climate Accord the Petersburg climate
dialogue serve as a preparation for the
next UN climate conference that's
planned for December
let's talk about this more now with DW
political correspondent Rupert Vita vald
good morning Rupert the Petersburg
dialogues they've been around for 10
years now but this time around the
climate that they're happening in is
very different from the first one 10
years ago
absolutely this meeting here in Berlin
shows what obstacles have to be overcome
for this real United Nations Climate
Change Conference at the end of the year
the idea of this petersburg book dialog
is but once was to to set the frame for
for the for the bigger conferences of
the United Nations to prepare them and
to form a Coalition of the Willing but
now this Coalition of the Willing has
been more or less fallen apart as we see
the United States have left the Paris
climate quote Brazil as thinking of
leaving it and several other countries
are thinking about if they are leaving
why should we still take part and even
Germany is not reaching its own goals so
many obstacles have to overcome have to
be overcome and there's much to be done
at this meeting here in Berlin so that
the meeting at the end of the year in
Santiago de Chile is really prepared
okay not only is Germany not meeting its
own stated goals but there there's no
agreement emerging right now as to where
the country goes from here
absolutely Germany promised once to cut
40 percent of its carbon dioxide
emissions by next year this is something
that won't be reached this is already
clear and several other goals are very
high I are highly in question right now
and there are several politicians for
instance the environmental Minister
saying we have to do more but Angela
Merkel's government up till now has said
we can't do very much more because then
we would endanger our economy for
instance the car making industry one of
the biggest sectors but nothing has been
reached so far okay then this puts the
Environment Minister at odds as we've
been saying with with amla Marco who was
referred to once upon a time is the
climate change Chancellor but her actual
record on that issue has left a lot of
people disappointed
in 14 years as German Chancellor Angela
Merkel has giving a New Year speech each
year but only mentioned climate change
in eight of them nonetheless in 2007 the
media began calling her the climate
Chancellor and shortly thereafter she
took advantage of a photo-op in
Greenland in front of melting glaciers
being here today and seeing the urgency
that confronts us will give me strength
to work together with the environment to
get something done Minister Gonzaga
Judith Itsuki of industrial Merkel has
declared internationally that global
warming is a crucial topic under her
chairmanship government leaders of the
eight biggest industrial countries
agreed to a 50% reduction in greenhouse
gas emissions by the year 2050 but in
Germany things move very slowly the goal
of reducing emissions by 40 percent in
the following year was not met by a long
shot
Merkel was too timid in approaching the
transportation and car industries
instead her government decided to
continue using coal and stop the
expansion of renewable energy
nonetheless her image remained that of
the climate Chancellor despite the
meager results in her 2019 New Year
speech she included aerial images of
hurricanes and draughts for the first
time I know that on the one hand you
have this unbelievable beauty on the
other hand you see how vulnerable the
basic necessities of life are so dealing
with climate change is absolutely vital
but young people are losing faith in
Merkel those who take part in the Friday
for future demonstrations every week
were only two or three years old when
Merkel was declared climate Chancellor
the co2 emissions in Germany have hardly
been reduced since then for these kids
the Merkel fairytale has a sad ending
okay and the issues that the core of
that will be addressed during the
Chancellor's speech later today
Rupert it comes at a time when the her
coalition government is looking for some
kind of a way to move forward some kind
of agreement among us all as members
absolute we already heard about the
proposal from the environmental Minister
who says we need to support of the
French proposal to cut down all
emissions by 2050 to zero which is
something Angela Merkel always said this
is not going to happen
the environmental Minister wants to
introduce some sort of a carbon tax here
in Germany something angler Michael
always said this is not going to happen
especially as there's the label tax on
it but even angler Michael knows that
climate change is gonna cost something
for the people and she already said
there is going to be a price tag but we
don't know which already so something is
gonna come up and we're all very eager
to know what she's going to propose
today okay and everyone's gonna be
looking at that possible price tag as
well
Rupert thanks very much for that